congratulations on completing Khan for
educators initial course your efforts to
grow your professional learning inspire
all of us at Khan Academy while this
course has come to an end
Khan Academy offers other communication
channels and opportunities to keep
learning from the teacher dashboard
click on the resources tab here you will
find additional materials that may help
you use Khan Academy with your students
also check out the Help Center where you
can find a series of articles including
frequently asked questions and guides
for students teachers and parents in
addition from the Help Center you can
report a technical problem and receive
assistance from our support team to
learn more about Khan Academy's training
initiatives or other projects keep an
eye on your inbox we'll always make an
effort to keep our educators in the know
you can also follow our teacher
exclusive Facebook group and teach with
Khan Twitter account for additional
teacher focused videos like interviews
for their teacher ambassadors or past
webinars visit our khan academy teacher
youtube channel or for more and remote
teaching and learning check out our keep
everyone learning site for resources for
students teachers and families available
in English and Spanish finally if you'd
be willing to share a few moments of
your time we'd love to get your feedback
on this course and how we can best
support teachers everywhere if you'd be
willing to provide feedback please use
the survey found in this lesson if you
have any difficulties accessing the
survey please contact teacher education
at Khan Academy org once again
congratulations on completing confer
educators initial course we look forward
to hearing more about the incredible
things you are doing with your students